with law schools starting back up I
thought it would be a good time to talk
about the five biggest myths about law
school success and how you can do better
by working less first let's define what
is law school success for the most part
law school success is getting good
grades to enable you to get the job that
you want when you graduate from law
school law school is a means to an end
and generally as a professional school
is a means to the job that you want to
work as a career generally for the rest
of your life and for most people that
means working as a lawyer in the
circumstances that they want but it
would be a Pyrrhic victory to go through
law school only to lose more than you
gain for example if you had a heart
attack for all the stress that you were
under or lost your health because of all
the bad habits that you gained in law
school so I wanted to talk about some of
the most pernicious myths about law
school success and the first one that
most people think of when they think of
law school is that people work all the
time now certainly law school is going
to take a lot of work but no one can
work all the time no one can do
all-nighter
after all-nighter after all-nighter
there has to be time for hobbies one
person once asked me if they would have
time for their hobbies in law school and
my response was that not only is it
possible to keep your hobbies in law
school but I think it's essential law
school is like a gas that expands to
fill the space around it law school will
take up all of the time that you allow
it to take up and of course a lot of
that is necessary don't get me wrong but
everybody has to have a life outside of
law school everybody has to have hobbies
and things they do on the side so what I
recommend is paying yourself first if
your health is important to you work out
in the morning and then let Law School
fill the available time after that if
learning to play the piano is important
to you carve out an hour of the day to
learn piano before you do all of your
law school work and on top of that when
you focus on the high value work you'll
have a reasonable amount of time left
over for other things those people that
focus on the busy
the case briefing for example they might
not have all that much extra time
because they're doing things that aren't
going to help them on the final exam but
if you focus on the high value work like
synthesizing the law into your outline
doing practice exams learning the
strategies for test taking you'll have a
lot of time left over focus on what's
most important and don't work all the
time that brings me to the second myth
about law school success which is that
the smartest people will always get the
best grades what's funny is that it's
clear when law school starts that some
people are extraordinarily smart and
some people are smarter than others but
the funny thing is that those smartest
people are rarely the people that get
the top grades because just because
you're smart in an abstract sense in an
IQ sense that doesn't mean that you're
going to focus on the most important
things and so many people focus on
studying the law alone without focusing
on how to take law school exams which is
an equally important part in fact we did
an entire video on the two keys to
success one is learning the law itself
and the other is mastering the test and
if you do one at the exclusion of the
other you're probably not going to do as
well so just because you are smart in
the sense that you can memorize things
faster or have a high IQ does not
guarantee success in law school the
third myth is along the same lines and
it's that everything in law school is
about hard work the hardest workers will
be the most successful just as with the
myth about the smartest people in law
school just because you work hard
doesn't mean that you're doing work
that's important there's so much bad
advice about law school advice that will
cause people to do far more busy work
than is necessary there are law schools
who in their orientation packets tell
people that they should case brief every
case in law school and that is just a
huge waste of time but because the law
school is the one that's saying this
information it would be reasonable for
someone to think that they should do
this work and that if they're doing a
huge amount of work and killing
themselves doing case brief night after
night after night that they're getting
ahead when
they're just running in circles so just
because you're doing hard work doesn't
mean you're doing the work that's going
to result in a successful law school
career oh and by the way feedback is the
one thing that has been scientifically
proven to increase your grades in law
school we did a whole video on that
check it out in the link below
hard work alone does not equal success
the final myth about law school success
is that grades are enough now certainly
grades are important and they are
probably the most important thing that
you should focus on in law school but
don't fool yourself to think that grades
alone are enough to get the job that you
want the legal field is still a field
that relies on networks it relies on who
you know so regardless of what job you
want when you graduate don't overlook
the human element make friends with your
professors go into office hours make
friends with other attorneys in the
field other administrators in your law
school because these are the people that
are going to be able to for example
write letters of recommendation these
are the people that might introduce you
to other lawyers who you might want to
work for they might have connections to
big firms they might have connections to
judges who you might want to clerk for
the human element cannot be overstated
and many law schools have the on-campus
interview process and that's great but
not everybody gets a job through OCI you
shouldn't put all of your eggs in one
basket and you should still try and
network even during your 1l year it is
much better to go to a professor whose
office hours you went to many times and
to whom you demonstrated a real
understanding of the law and passion for
the legal field to ask that professor
for a letter of recommendation after the
semester is over remember you're going
to have to apply for 1l summer jobs
probably at the end of your first
semester even before grades come out and
the only thing at most you'll have are
your 1l grades so you want to
be able to talk to professor's for
letters of recommendation you want to be
able to talk to other lawyers to perhaps
have an internship or a clerkship or a
summer associate ship and don't overlook
the fact that you still have to network
and that grades are seldom enough to get
your dream legal job so don't assume
that your grades are going to be enough
maybe you're not gonna get the high
grades that you think you should be
entitled to you may have to fall back on
that human element and regardless it's
always better to backstop grades with a
personal network that you developed
while in law school to make sure that
you can attain the perfect legal job
when you graduate hopefully that was
helpful if you like this video please
click like and subscribe for more law
school crushing tips also please
download the free checklist below to
ensure your successful law school career
from everyone here at legal eagle thanks
for stopping by
[Music]
you
[Music]